the years long war on Christmas
continues to rage on
but now Christmas is finally winning now
cultural conservatives must turn our
attention elsewhere move the war on
Christmas forward to the more insidious
struggle the war on Advent we will
analyze what conservatives can learn
from Advent then President George Bush
dies at 94 we examine his legacy a
climate change alarmism burns down Paris
and you're gonna be shocked to hear this
Alexandria okay Jie Cortez says
something nonsensical I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt Oh
[Music]
well there's no place like home for the
holidays so nice to be back here in LA
and I obviously the war on Christmas has
been going on for a long time some deny
it many people deny it
we will show the evidence for it but I
want to move in a new direction I want
to move the war on Christmas forward
we're winning we're making up ground
Christmas is winning Santa Claus is on
top of a tank and there's a new place to
go which is Advent the people not paying
attention to Advent conservatives
Christians religious irreligious
everybody can learn a lot from advents
and we'll get to that in a second but
first let's make a little money honey
with candid Co candid listen if you need
to fix crooked teeth crowding teeth gaps
between your teeth you don't have a nice
little smile
then you need candid Canada's helping
people gain confidence through
accessible and affordable orthodontic
care it makes the process of
straightening your teeth convenient and
easy by having the customer take the
process into their own hands straighter
and brighter teeth in an average of six
months and it cost sixty five percent
less than braces braces used to be
really expensive you know it's it's such
a people notice your smile right away if
you don't have a great smile it's so
easy to fix it now and inexpensive do it
it makes a huge difference
candid makes clear aligners they're sent
directly to your home they are
customized specifically for you to
straighten your teeth the aligners fix
crooked teeth crowding protrusion and
gaps the first step is to purchase their
modeling kit which will be sent to your
home you can take impressions of your
teeth I got mine I love it
the modeling kit is $95 that's the
retail price an orthodontist review to
your specific case provides you with the
3d preview of what your treatment will
look like best part it takes the
treatment time as an average of six
months will save you literally thousands
of dollars compared to the other guys
you're one step away from getting
straight or whiter teeth like little old
me take advantage of Canada's risk-free
modeling guarantee plus when you use my
dedicated link candid co.com /co FFA CoV
fe fe save 25% on your modeling kit a
great idea for the holidays candid code
comm / go FFA CoV fe fe to get 25% off
the price of your modeling kit gated
code comm / go FFA let's get to the war
on Christmas obviously some
conservatives don't believe that there
is a war on Christmas it actually turns
out the majority of Republicans 56% of
Republicans do not believe this is a war
on Christmas I think largely this is
from the fiscally conservative socially
liberal set they don't want to get oh
they said I'm not one of these people I
you know I just want to go and I'm a
cool guy and I want to go to cocktail
parties I don't care about silly things
like the war on Christmas but there
obviously is one the evidence is all
around in 2005 Boston got rid of its
Christmas tree it officially changed the
name of the Christmas tree to the
holiday tree what holiday is it for or I
gosh I don't know what is it is it Arbor
Day is that I guess actually that is the
one example it could be for Arbor Day in
2005 Walmart got rid of Christmas from
its marketing materials target same
thing Best Buy in 2006 got rid of
Christmas from their marketing materials
the classic example is Starbucks
Starbucks for years and years had little
snowmen and snowflakes and Christmas
trees and things on their cups then in
2015 they decided they were gonna take
out anything that even vaguely resembled
Christmas paraphernalia and it was just
a red cup and that's what this is all
about the war on Christmas is about this
bland tedious taking the particular out
of life the thing that makes life
enjoyable or the details the particulars
that's why we like diversity that's why
we like talking to people who don't
agree with us maybe or who see the world
a little differently that's why we like
eating different kinds of food watching
different movies we don't just watch the
same thing day after day reading
different books we like that diversity
and the diversity comes out in the
particular it seems to me with the war
on Christmas people want with the left
once broadly is for us all to be exactly
the same look the same dress the same
talk the same just be gray and like that
that new meme going around the NPC meme
it's the meme of the non-player
character and it makes out the left to
be just like robots who have nothing
differentiating them from everybody else
that is what this event it's about
taking away the particularity of the
season and the particular particularity
of which holiday is being celebrated we
can say Happy Holidays but which holiday
are you talking about you're not talking
about Arbor Day so they did this at
Starbucks in 2015 there was both a
backlash from some cultural
conservatives and then people pretending
that there was a much larger backlash to
make fun of cultural conservatives so
the neck
year it got even worse the cup got it
was a green cup and it just had a mosaic
of random people on it didn't have
anything to do with New Year's nothing
to do with Hanukkah nothing to do with
Christmas not even anything to do with
Kwanzaa which is a completely made-up
holiday it's a contrived atheist
socialist holiday made up in the 1960s
by a professor at Cal State Long Beach
it has nothing to do with it has no
tradition whatsoever it's just a
political fad that virtually nobody
celebrates anymore didn't even have that
it was just a green cup with a you know
what ostensibly should have been the
least offensive picture nobody could
have any problem with it trouble is it
wasn't saying anything it didn't
celebrate any particular holiday then
President Trump gets elected he
campaigns in part on the war on
Christmas he gets elected and you know
the Starbucks cup it starts you get a
little bit more a little bit more shades
of Christmas in there this year oh man I
go in on November 1st
they're already blasting Christmas music
wall-to-wall they are already they've
got four different Christmas cups a
little Holly in there the big Christmas
blend of go it's great so Christmas is
winning the war on Christmas and that is
a wonderful thing I'm happy to hear it
but because we can never just be happy
and take a win we now have to look at
the next problem well I'm happy I am
celebrating that we are winning the war
on Christmas President Trump I don't
want people to think I'm not grateful
for a president Trump campaigned on this
people made fun of him for it and it is
true just anecdotally you go to places
now and you hear Merry Christmas more
often at the the Christmas tree lighting
at the White House here is President
Trump making this point in his typically
subtle way Merry Christmas everybody we
just have to say it all together Merry
Merry Christmas it's great to be with
you
and let's light the tree First Lady will
do the honors we have to say this we
have to say it just in case you didn't
miss by in case you missed it so you
remember during the Obama era a Barack
Obama took Christmas out of the White
House Christmas card just said happy
holidays have a good holiday but there
was no Christmas in there this was a big
break with tradition now a
representative Democrat rep jungkook got
the Trump White
Christmas card he said it's the gaudiest
Christmas card he's ever seen it's
gigantic it's oversized it's red it's
got gold all over it very very Trumpy it
says Merry Christmas written right on
top I'm offended that I did not get one
of these cards but c'est la vie these
things happen so so in any case they
they've got you know the Christmas cards
out there Barack Obama you'll remember
during his administration started a
fight with the Little Sisters of the
Poor he wanted to make a group of nuns
pay for abortions this was obviously a
terrible thing people shouldn't be
forced to violate their conscience
especially nuns and what a Donald Trump
do he comes into office he invites a
group of nuns in a full habit just as
Christian as they can possibly look to
come and sing at the Christmas tree
lighting here they are
[Applause]
[Music]
just lovely turns out that group of nuns
there they are very popular musicians
they've had billboard and Amazon number
one recordings they're number one in
classical they're not beating out ariana
grande but they're still doing pretty
well so this is all great this is a big
embrace of this you even got Hollywood
stories like Chris Pratt talking about
Christmas in explicitly religious terms
Chris Pratt gave an impassioned delivery
he was describing the Gospel of Luke
kind of like Charlie Brown at the annual
candlelight procession at Disneyland
over the weekend here's Chris Pratt
about two thousand years ago God sends
an angel named Gabriel to a city in
Galilee named Nazareth to a virgin who
was betrothed to a man named Joseph of
the house of David as a descendant of
King David that Virgin's name was Mary
and having come in the angel said to her
rejoice highly favored one the Lord is
with you blessed are you among women the
Bible says when she saw him she was
troubled at his saying and considered
what manner of greeting this was that
seems confusing to me so I'll just
paraphrase she was kind of scared
because an angel just fell it from the
ceiling I love that guy I also love the
way that he takes these very serious
he's obviously quite Christian and he
takes these serious Christian concepts
and then he does infuse it with his
movie star young guy exuberant energy
did this at an award ceremony where he
told people to believe in God and
understand that they have a soul and the
soul matters but he just doesn't his way
that's not pedantic it's not it's just
really really good so it's great to see
him do that that's that's all wonderful
now that we're in
the Christmas season there is this rush
to rush it there's this surge of people
trying to rush our way to Christmas
we're back in we've got the
particularity of it because it doesn't
make sense why our people talk about
it's the most wonderful time of the year
oh it's your family and it's almost
wonderful - why is it wonderful why is
this time wonderful if it's just the
holidays if it's not about a holiday if
it's not about a holiday that celebrates
something then why are people so happy
and excited and nice it's not just the
turkey you know it's not just people eat
turkey at other points of the year why
is it what makes it different than
Thanksgiving what makes it different
than the fourth of July the next stage
of this the thing that I think we could
all use a little help on is Advent
because people forget Advent Advent is
that period of time before Christmas
it's this time that the four Sundays
before Christmas in the Christian
tradition celebrate four mysteries that
are supposed to prepare us for Christmas
it's this penitential season it's more
of a solemn season it's not all dancing
around the Christmas tree yet in the
four mysteries that are celebrated our
death judgment Heaven and Hell we said
we explore these mysteries we meditate
on these mysteries that that have
mankind has considered for all of human
history when we were living in the caves
we have contemplated these mysteries
what is death what does death mean what
is judgment will there be a judge will I
have to pay for my sins what is heaven
is there hope of something after this
world what is hell will I be punished in
the Hereafter what what his punishment
look like these are mysteries you know
the right has always been really strong
in taking Christmas aside in the war on
Christmas and the left has constantly
been trying to drive out Christmas
celebrations and it's very easy to
understand that concept but very few
people are sticking up for Advent and
Advent could really teach us something
whether you're a Christian whether
you're not Christian whether you're on
the Left whether you're on the right
everybody could really use it we're it's
such a fever pitch right now we're all
at each other's throats
politics is quite divided we're really
angry to each other the left is
especially angry at the right and we're
missing fundamental eternal mysteries
major major questions beginning with
death that was yesterday was the first
Sunday of Advent we're now in the Advent
season and this one I think it really
really matters because sometimes when
people are at a fever pitch in politics
I sometimes think do you not realize
you're gonna die some day John Maynard
Keynes The Economist said in the long
run we're all dead so I don't know if
your policies will work in the long run
in the long run we're all dead and when
we contemplate that mystery I think it
makes us appreciate each other a lot
more appreciate our country a lot more
and appreciate Christmas which is coming
up we will get to that if is you know
because Advent leads to Christmas which
is sweet as honey
and speaking of honey honey we'll help
you buy all of your Christmas gifts and
save a lot of money you know how much I
love honey I've been an evangelist for
honey for years before my show existed
before the daily wire existed I love
honey honey is the way to always get the
lowest price on the Internet
especially important when you're buying
your gifts Hanukkah just started I think
it's the second night of Hanukkah
tonight
christmas is coming up you're gonna need
to get your gifts honey is a free
shopping tool that automatically saves
you money by searching the internet for
the best promo codes whenever you shop
online that means you get the best deals
without even trying on your favorite
sites like Amazon eBay
j.crew Walmart Sephora Expedia and more
in fact honey has already saved it's 10
million members an average of 28 dollars
and 61 cents I couldn't tell you the
last time I used honey because I only
use honey I exclusively use honey I've
been buying people Christmas presents
online I've been buying people you know
and anything jewelry books clothing
everything I use it all the time I've
saved a ton of money and and especially
for Christmas season it saves me
hundreds of dollars if not more buying
gifts for my family honey has over 10
million members
it has over 100,000 plus five-star
reviews on the google chrome store right
now it is so easy to add add honey of
your browser especially you know during
the holiday season get it for free at
join honey calm slash cough FAC OVF efe
that is two words join honey calm slash
cough fa c OV e fe fe and that's my
Christmas present to you that's my gift
to you as I saved you a bunch of money
on your Christmas shopping so this is
Advent nobody wants to talk about Advent
we want to start playing Christmas music
starting on November 1st
I suppose this is evidence that people
can never be happy you know last year I
was complaining that Starbucks didn't do
enough for Christmas now they start
Christmas on November 1st and I said no
that's too soon but maybe maybe they're
just not getting it wrong you need a
middle ground you need to have a little
balance here and if you rush Christmas
it's like rushing through dinner it's
like you sit down to a beautiful dinner
and you've got steak and turkey and
potatoes and all of this and you sit
down and used to start eating pudding
cups and then you saw I'm full I already
ate all my pudding cups no you want to
build up and you want to remember why we
need Christmas in the first place why is
Christmas the most wonderful time of the
year why is Chris Pratt reciting the
narrative from Luke well why is he
reciting the infancy narrative why do we
watch a Charlie Brown Christmas whereas
it was reciting this this amazing moment
in the woods in in somewhere around the
Year Zero when in a little cave in a
little manger surrounded by livestock
because there was no room at the end the
God who created all of us the divine
love that made us in the universe
becomes flesh enters into the creation
as a little baby born on a traveling
Road
born in the lowest of the low inside of
a cave and why does that matter what
does that mean why are why do we need
that to happen the reason we need that
to happen is because of death and
judgment in heaven and hell you know in
our culture we are so afraid of death
yes I see this all the time when I read
all of the tech blogs and science blogs
every other day there's somebody in
Silicon Valley who says that we're about
to find the cure for death oh we're so
close to the cure for death all those
all those people who lived before us
they sure missed out because now they're
dead but we're gonna live forever and
this reminds me of every foolish ruler
for all of history every Pharaoh every
guy who was certain he was going to find
the elixir of life and he would live
forever he looks and we make fun of
these people because we know death is a
fact of life I don't know that we would
want to live forever in this world I
don't think I would in this world of
decay and corruption I don't want to
live forever in this world but
we will die but now the cosmetics
industry has exploded
people spend evermore money on products
on surgeries on Botox on plastic surgery
on whatever to make it look as though
they are not aging to try to pretend
that we're not going to die I go to
funerals you know people who are not
religious friends of mine who are
atheistic and it's always so sad they're
these really sad celebrations of life
they call it and I guess that's nice you
like the person you want to send them
off but you don't know what you're
celebrating because in in those moments
people don't understand what death is
they don't know is there a heaven is
there a hell where is this going what
does it mean is life some random chance
the left has convinced us that there is
no meaning to life that there is just
life is a random cosmic accident
it's a tale told by an idiot full of
sound and fury signifying nothing and so
when we die that's a it's just a pure
tragedy there's no comedy to it there's
no hope what is it
obviously religious people say if some
religious people say that there is life
after death the death isn't the end but
death does have a meaning they have
different explanations why did death
come into the world why do we have to
die why are we in a creation such that
we have to die what is the the biblical
answer is because man is free man has
free will man sinned and so because man
sinned debt sin and death entered into
the world and corruption and decay and
that's why so there's death the the
second mystery is judgment why in it
we're in this world where we say don't
judge don't be so judgey don't you cry
young man don't how why are you being so
judgey there is no right or wrong it's
just like you know it's whatever it is
this this throwing off ideas of judgment
has come back on us and we're now our
entire ethical discourse basically
amounts to if it feels good do it that's
that's about the level of moral
discourse that we have right now in the
country we can't explain why it's not
good to do certain things why it's not
good to like watch a bunch of porn and
go carousing all the time and stop by
where wherever else you know because in
one particular sin of our culture is is
that sex is everywhere I mean there's
ill
sins in the culture one of them is dead
so it's a good example because we say oh
if it feels good it's not doesn't matter
it's okay we oh well as long as you're
not hurting anybody or if you're hurting
them but it's okay and they kind of like
it or well you know that's that's what
our discourse has gotten down to and
you'll even have people dishonestly
quoting but the Bible quoting the
scripture and they'll say well you know
judge not lest ye be judged
correct I'm not judging a person I'm not
going to condemn a person but we must
make moral judgments it's the only way
that we can live the the only way that
we can get out of bed in the morning is
to make a judgment say should I get out
of bed or should I should I stay in bed
all day and sleep you get you go down to
your kitchen and you make a judgment you
say do I eat Cheerios or do I eat bacon
and eggs I never eat Cheerios I only
make it and eggs because I'm an adult
but you know some people have these
judgments they have to do I smoked three
cigars tonight or 17 cigars tonight what
am I going to do these are all judgments
but we don't want to have those
judgments and I think it's in part
because we we have the sense of sin
mankind has always had the sense of sin
everybody sins constantly we're always
making terrible decisions but that's
that's why we need a correct if that's
why we need Christmas that's why we need
to at least atone that's why we need to
accept a moral standard but because we
don't accept any of these things now we
have the sense of sin and we're so
anxious we so don't want to be judged
for it that we're trying to abdicate all
of our moral reasoning maybe this may be
the second weekend in Advent could do a
little something even for conservatives
who have that kind of thought then
there's heaven what is heaven is there
is there hope after death if there's
judgment is there a hope of something
beyond this world UK you know the the
theological virtues are faith hope and
charity without hope we have nothing
when you enter when Dante enters into
hell in the poem the Divine Comedy
on top of Hell it says abandon all hope
ye who enter we have a spate of despair
in America we have suicides way on the
rise among teenagers it's up 70 percent
among the whole culture it's very high
especially a middle-aged men middle-aged
white men in particular killing
themselves in spades a ton of people
taking antidepressant drugs that number
is
way way up and now for the for the
second year in a row for the first time
in half of a century the average life
expectancy is decreasing because of
despair what does that have to do with
heaven we'll get to that in one second
but first before you die before you get
to heaven before the Judgment you need
to take care of your health not in a
vain way but because you because you
want to live your life to the fullest
and that can feel overwhelming that is
why I love Omax three ultra pure
supplements om x3 is the purest way to
get them it's ultra pure it's natural
it's not going to completely mess with
your body it's not some wacky chemical
that's trying to do it's it is pure and
it's good for your health try Oh max
calm /co f f/a go there right now today
and get a box of Oh max ultra pure for
free with your first purchase that is
try Oh max calm /qf facl v fe fe you
will get a free box of o max 3 with your
first purchase this is the purest option
it contains nearly 94% high quality
Omega threes you will not get fish burps
that is its that is a kind of a
depressing thing when you have fish
burps don't do it many Omega threes on
the market this is the purest most
concentrated one has various health
benefits it alleviates a joint pain
inflammation and muscle soreness and for
the time that you got on this world it
will make you feel a little better
it can help memory or cardiovascular
health brain health do it Oh max 3 has
sold over half a million boxes of
ultra-pure due to its cult-like
following it comes with a 60-day
money-back guarantee you'll have plenty
of time to try it and really feel the Oh
max difference go to try um XCOM slash
cough f8c o fe fe fe today get a box of
Oh max ultra Oh max 3 ultra pure for
free with your first purchase try o max
calm slash cough f a free box of Oh max
rupees and first purchase how many times
do I need to tell you that right now go
try o max calm slash go f f/a terms and
conditions apply they always do heaven
is there any hope
I see people despairing and I know there
were mental health problems people have
but mental health problems doesn't
explain the surge in suicides it doesn't
explain the cert the reason why average
life expectancy for the second year in a
row for the first time in 50 years in
America has actually decreased decreased
in the
wealthiest most prosperous most free
most equitable country in the world
people are not living as long is because
of suicide and drug addiction drug
overdoses why are people killing
themselves
with drugs and other means it's because
they are despairing despair means with
it without hope it is the absence of
hope spero are a is to is to hope and
it's the absence of that but what are we
hoping for well there's I various things
I I am hoping one thing that kind of
keeps me going is once I finish this
show I'm gonna go up in smoke a stogie
because we've got the backstage Holiday
Edition coming up that's one thing maybe
tonight I'll get to go see sweet little
ELISA
that's a hope I've got a hope that you I
don't know that the show gets really big
I've got a hope that I'll get to go to
some more colleges and give more talks
I've got all of these various hopes I
have plenty of hopes but what are my
ultimate hopes it has to transcend the
physical world because ultimately I'm
gonna die no one here gets out alive
maybe one guy I know I know one guy who
did and he's about to be born in a few
weeks but other than that it's very
difficult to you know once you're in the
ground you're gonna stay there for a
long period of time so what is that
ultimate hope is there somewhere that I
can go does my soul live on what is my
soul is my soul physical or is it
metaphysical is it is it a spiritual
what is that so the other reason you
need this is because we live in a really
nice culture where everything is super
Pleasant all the time and we have cool
electronics and TVs going and it's all
just really really nice great but as a
result of that when things go wrong
people lose their minds you know
Millennials the most coddled generation
in American history for kids at college
right now there was a study done out of
Arizona State University
it showed that two years after the 2016
election students were a quarter of
college students were suffering from
symptoms of post-traumatic stress
disorder and that's not made up they
weren't just pretending they were
actually suffering clinically high
levels of stress stress levels as high
as people who experienced a mass
shooting incident seven months after the
mass shooting that's how high it is
because a Republican won the White House
that's when
things are so nice when we're in a
decadent society when kids are coddled
and protected from the harsh realities
of the world then when things go wrong
they're so fragile they break they crack
what why is that when what is the
ultimate hope if you don't have an
ultimate hope then once those things
crack you're gonna fall into a pit of
despair so what is heaven and then the
fourth mystery what is hell what is
there hell Antonin Scalia did an
interview with New York magazine with
this very glib woman a number of years
ago and he mentioned that he believed in
Hell and she made fun of him she said oh
my gosh it must be very scary to believe
in Hell in the devil he said you know
that's this is basic Catholic theology
that hell exists do you know how out of
touch you are with America most of
Americans believe in Hell and in the
devil most of people throughout history
have believed in Hell in the devil
why does hell matter hell matters
because it means there is divine justice
well we like to do both in religion and
in our sort of pseudo religions you hear
all these people who say I'm spiritual
but not religious oh I'm not a Christian
but I like Christian teachings oh I okay
whatever they what they try to do is
they want all the really nice comforting
things and they don't want any of those
harsh realities they want the heaven
they don't want the hell they want a God
without wrath to lead a people without
sin into a kingdom without judgment
through the ministrations of a Christ
without a cross to quote a famous
theologian so if there is no hell what
does that mean it means God is all
merciful we know God is merciful he is
love God is love but but without if
there is no hell then there is not that
justice and we don't have the human
freedom you know so much what what Chris
Pratt is talking about at that candle
lighting ceremony is this incredible
moment in the world at the Annunciation
when the angel comes down and tells Mary
that she's gonna give birth to Jesus the
angel comes down God's grace pours down
on the world and and then heaven holds
its breath because Mary a sense she
still has free will she can turn away
from God she can say no but she says I
am The Lord's servant may his will be
done we have free will this is the
defining feature of humanity
we have freedom we have liberty and we
can reject God we can choose hell if we
want to we can go right down there we
can we can choose hell on earth we can
choose hell beyond earth it is it is up
to us God does not deny us that dignity
of freedom
what a beautiful thing it can be that
there is justice how beautiful a thing
that we have that Liberty you know in
America we talk about Liberty so much
our country is that a free country
founded on life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness but how do we pursue that
happiness and what is the substance of
that Liberty why is it so important why
is it so essential how do we exercise it
and when we use our Liberty and we abuse
our Liberty how do we get mercy how do
we redeem ourselves that is what we are
waiting for at Christmas that's what
Christmas is about it's not you know I
like I wouldn't recommend discussing
that or at your office Christmas party
I don't know when when you know Suzie
the secretary is sloshed on on eggnog
you know and you start discussing death
judgment heaven and hell that might be a
little bit of a downer you know
everyone's playing Rock around the
Christmas tree and you're there with a
little fire and brimstone I'm not
suggesting that but in in the moments
when you're not at those Christmas
parties like that are all over the place
or holiday party or whatever in the
moments when you're actually
contemplating the season and the reason
for the joy of this season think about
those things because it seems that maybe
it seems a little sad or inconvenient we
don't want to think about it the reason
that we have despair
flying throughout our culture is because
precisely because we don't want to think
about it this is the season to do it
don't skip it because if you skip that
season you are going to skip the entire
celebration we have so much more to talk
about we've got to talk about President
George Bush dying the legacy of George
Bush people on the left and the right
are getting it wrong the Paris riots
this is these are my favorite riots as
far as riots go these ones couldn't be
better because the mainstream media
won't report on the actual cause of the
riots which is global warming alarmism
we will get to that in a bit and we've
got a lot more if we've got time but
coming up tonight let's talk about hope
talk about awaiting wonderful things
coming up tonight don't miss our next
episode of daily wire backstage Holiday
Edition
and at this
I have to defend the word holiday here
because it actually isn't Christmas yet
we are in Advent and it's Hanukkah it's
the second night of Hanukkah so we're
being ecumenical it's the holiday
edition daily wire god king jeremy
boring ben shapiro Andrew Klavan Alicia
kress and little ol me we'll be talking
politics culture and why frozen leftist
tears make me most beautiful snowflakes
they're all unique they're all
individual so be sure to tune in as
always only daily wire subscribers get
to ask the questions so make sure to
subscribe today also if you're a
subscriber you lucky duck you will be
able to see Andrew Clayton's next
chapter of another Kingdom performed by
whom performed by moi today subscribers
get exclusive access to episode 9 titled
orosco and it's coming to an end this
season and this this season I tell you
when I go to these campus speeches you
know I was on the road for I've been on
the road forever I've been just going
all over the country I think I've been
to it 57 States I've been to all 57
states that Barack Obama went to and
people come up to me they'll say Michael
Michael I love the show say oh thank you
so much for watching did you caught it
yesterday they say oh no Michael I don't
mean your show I don't mean the Michael
no sir I mean I mean another Kingdom I
love another kingdom so it's gotten
really good numbers if you want a nice
cozy little Christmas read either to
listen or to watch it with the amazing
art this is a really good one curl up by
the fire it's it's great because drew
did all the work and I just have to read
it so go check it out if you're not a
subscriber you want people to watch new
episodes of season two until Friday so
what on earth are you waiting for
go to daily wire com subscribe to watch
the first and second seasons of another
Kingdom you get all the shows you know
all that here's what you need it's
beginning to look a lot like Christmas
those you know that snow is much thicker
and fluffier than water so when the the
left is snow flakes start pouring down
those salty ones you're probably going
to need two tumblers if you already have
one get another go to daily we're calm
we'll be right back with a lot more
President Bush died this was not
shocking news I got the news
you know I'm when I saw the update and I
wasn't exactly thinking you know oh did
he flip his Mustang did he although
frankly with President Bush he was still
jumping out of airplanes at age 90 but a
life well-lived you know good guy he was
a war hero people I think are getting
reactions to this wrong on both sides I
guess really really my first reaction
was we all knew he was not long for this
world his wife died earlier this year
he's had a million health problems he's
lived a good life now he's getting his
eternal reward but I was thinking you
know Nixon dead four dead
Reagan dead Bush dead but Jimmy Carter
you know Jimmy Carter in fact you cannot
stump that guy he had brain cancer for
goodness sakes he beat it that guy he's
gonna outlive all of us Jimmy Carter
best best of health to President Carter
so so President Bush died and some
conservatives were a little down on
Bush's career why well George Bush
Senior was not a conservative he he was
running basically from the establishment
wing of the Republican Party than the
moderate ring of the Republican Party
think he backed Goldwater so he did have
that in him a little bit but he was the
moderate guy anti conservative movement
broadly he he coined the term voodoo
economics to refer to Ronald Reagan's
economic plans supply-side economics
which defined the conservative movement
for so long he was a supporter of
Planned Parenthood for a very long time
so that worked some conservatives he
abandoned Richard Nixon you know called
on Nixon to resign he he raised taxes he
you know one of the first expressions
that I ever learned as a kid I think I
was 2 years old was read my lips no new
taxes my grandfather taught it to me and
the irony this is what George Bush said
this was his promise he said read my
lips no new taxes and then he
immediately just raised taxes and
probably cost him the 1992 election so
that bothers conservatives what else
what else are they harping on there
he very famously at the end of the Cold
War Ronald Reagan wins the Cold War and
then George Bush is there and he's
overseeing the dismantling of the Soviet
empire and he makes this way actually in
a few instances he talks about what the
new world order will look like and this
has bred a lot of conspiracy theories
and that there is some basis in what
certain people want world order to look
like but then it has this you know then
also the the tinfoil hats and the
spaceman come out here is what President
Bush actually said about that we have
before us the opportunity to forge for
ourselves and for future generations a
new world order a world for the rule of
law not the law of the jungle governs
the conduct of Nations when we are
successful and we will be we have a real
chance at this new world order an order
in which a credible United Nations can
use its peacekeeping role to fulfill the
promise and vision of the UN's founders
okay so people some conservatives who
are excitable react to this and they say
see it's a nefarious plan for just a
government to govern the whole world and
the total loss of freedom and
sovereignty and that's not my reaction
my reaction is oh he likes the United
Nations okay alright whatever that's
that's fine that's cute but what he's
really talking about is that prior to
the fall of the Berlin Wall prior to the
dismantling of the Soviet empire
we had a bipolar world we had the
American sphere the Western sphere the
free sphere and we had the communist
sphere the Soviet sphere and that there
was the world broken up between two
great powers after the fall of the
Berlin Wall
you had a new world order by definition
you have a new world order because
America is the only remaining superpower
and then the question was how are we
going to handle the dismantling of this
empire what role will the United States
play obviously it's the leader of the
world how much will we allow ourselves
to be governed by international super
national institutions like the United
Nations like the IMF like the EU like
what all of these all of these different
international organizations and
President Bush clearly favored a much
broader role for them
then conservatives do but whatever I
know he wasn't talking about going in
and you know making everyone loyal only
to one god emperor of the entire planet
that that isn't what he was talking
about either it was just a kind of
typical middle-of-the-road republicanism
that's the bad stuff and I got to tell
you in in the whole of a career that's
not the worst thing in the world because
the good aspects of President Bush's
legacy were really excellent he was a
true war hero shot down over the Pacific
I think he the youngest pilot right it
was basically the youngest pilot in the
war he survived he was able to survive
his plane crash he came up lifts a
totally admirable life went to Yale
started having kids captain of the
baseball team skullenbones left Yale he
could have easily gone into banking in
New York his family was a major Wall
Street family and he didn't he chose to
move to West Texas strike out on his own
make his own fortune his own way he was
able to do that he ran for office he
lost an election then he won he was the
head of the RNC I believe he was the
head of the CIA he had this long career
but the the reason I really really
admire George Bush is because he was a
totally loyal vice president to Ronald
Reagan he was he was really really loyal
he went out there sometimes you hear a
vice president's arguing that their
presidents trying to go out on their own
and he wasn't George Bush and Ronald
Reagan probably didn't agree on very
much but Reagan treated him with respect
and George Bush treated Reagan with the
utmost deference and respect he went out
he was always campaigning promoting the
president you didn't see a lot of leaks
from the office of the vice president
you didn't see him trying to undermine
Ronald Reagan he played his role and and
when Reagan was shot there was this
defining moment where George Bush then
comes in acting as the president and he
could have sat in Ronald Reagan's chair
before the cabinet and he didn't he sat
in his own chair and I Ronald Reagan
said about this that that's that when he
knew he had a truly loyal vice president
Bush was there he didn't want to make it
seem like he was coming in taking
advantage of a situation and so that's a
beautiful thing I mean he's a loyal guy
to the greatest president of the 20th
century that's that's a
legacy he lived an upright life he
there's not much more to say about that
and so you've got people on the left now
try some of them were saying he was a
great guy because they want to attack
Donald Trump some of them are saying he
was a terrible guy because the left just
hates conservatives and hates
Republicans and even people who they
mistakenly think are conservative who
aren't really conservative like George
Bush and so you've got that and then
you've got people on the right attacking
him because he wasn't conservative
enough my thought he was my first
president when I was born he was loyal
to Ronald Reagan the greatest president
of the of the 20th century
he helped dismantle the Soviet empire he
managed a successful and limited
operation in Desert Storm very
successful
he always had dignity out of the office
he didn't like Barack Obama he didn't
take the opportunity and just constantly
attack his successors he was an
all-around dignified guy hats off to him
lived a good life served well did good
had good things to do in American
politics helped to bring the Republican
Party to the right even though he
himself wasn't trying to do that as a
member of the Reagan Revolution he was
he did do that that's a good thing hats
off to your President Bush thanks for
all you did I hope you're enjoying your
eternal reward now Paris Oh Paris have
you been following these riots they
think this is the best riot ever the
riots aren't good people get injured I
hope people don't die you know it's
obviously that's very bad but as far as
riots go it's the best one ever because
it explains and demonstrates the
insanity of European leftism of
particularly environmentalism so far
four hundred people have been arrested
in these riots 200 people have been
injured 75,000 people have protested and
estimated 75,000 people going out on the
streets so what is the protest about
because in France people are protesting
all the time they're always striking go
and protests going on riots my priest
father George rut ler describes a
Frenchman as an Italian in a bad mood
you know they're always kind of angry
and ornery and oh right so that's fine
why are they doing it now they're doing
it now to protest throw environmentalist
politicians they're doing it to protest
a global war
alarmism they are rioting right now
because self-appointed elites who want
to pretend that the Sun Monster is a
more pressing problem than than what
people need in the here and now are
bankrupting these guys so for French
citizens were already hit by this
earlier in the year macron the president
of France said that he was going to
attack global warming and he was going
to institute a new fuel tax to convince
people to stop using fossil fuels so
they were already hit with this massive
tax increase in January more than 60% of
the cost of fuel in France comes from
taxes if they cut out those useless
taxes you would have cheap fuel all over
France now there is a new fuel tax why
to fight climate change this is what
Barack Obama tried to do this is what he
said he was pretty open about it before
he wasn't open about it he said yeah
we've got him we've got to raise the
cost for people to use oil and gas so
that it hurts them so that they have to
start using wind power or whatever other
imaginary thing doesn't really produce
that much energy so he was insisting on
this we got to make it hurt I was
elected but I know so much better than
the people macro knows so much peddled
it better than the French Obama knows so
much better than the Americans and he's
gonna hurt them he's gonna he's gonna
force them to lose money have a tough
time feeding their family so that we can
stop sending carbon dioxide into the
environment okay they did say initially
the oil was running out remember they
told us that here 10 years ago and then
now we're the biggest producer in the
world of oil and natural gas that's what
they're saying oh we're gonna run out we
need to do this their theory is getting
in the way of reality all the time these
environmentalists types the global
warming alarmists
talk about all of the climate refugees
all of the people whose lives are gonna
be upended by global warming and climate
change we haven't seen any of them yet
they don't exist yet but in the fantasy
world of the left they will exist just
in five more years the day after
tomorrow when are we gonna sit didn't
you say they were gonna be around in
2013 2015 no no no I said that you would
see climate refugees the day after
tomorrow what am I gonna see them day
after tomorrow okay I'll wait for the
day after tomorrow but in the
here-and-now in the reality there are we
are see
climate refugees it's the people
protesting in the streets in France they
are the climate refugees they're the
climate change refugees the ones who are
dealing it at their pocketbooks trying
to feed their families because frivolous
politicians like Emmanuel macron and
Barack Obama are trying to tax them into
oblivion they're using the the Sun
Monster as an excuse to steal more
government power and steal more wealth
from private citizens Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez you'll be shocked to hear is on
this exact same point she's speaking in
even more grandiose terms than Obama and
macro we did not know if we would be
capable of saving ourselves we have
we've done we've dug deep and we've done
what we thought was impossible we went
to the moon we electrified the nation we
established civil rights we enfranchise
to the country we did deep and we did it
we did it when no one else thought that
we could that's what we did with so many
of us won an election this year that's
what so many of us that's what we did
it's just the same stopping Jim Crow
stopping black people from being
murdered in America it's the same thing
as electing Alexandria cassio Cortez
isn't it it's almost I actually can't
even see the difference when I look at
Alexandria cassio Cortez when I stare
into her googly eyes all I see is Martin
Luther King jr. marching down on washing
that's what I see right is that what you
see no maybe not it this is a problem of
people who don't have any problems the
problem with people who don't have any
problems as they need to make problems
if they need to struggle and so when
everything is going so well they need to
focus on the Sun monster they need to
make up or they need to struggle because
we once struggle we want to achieve
things in life and when they're not
achieving the things they should achieve
they invent them and that is the the Sun
monster so the same thing she's
comparing to all in her mind I bet she
believes it in her mind global warming
which the predictions have consistently
been wrong we're told that even if we
had instituted the Paris climate
agreement
we would only reduce the temperature or
prevent 2 degrees of warming rather with
within the course of a hundred years and
and ironically we didn't take part in
the Paris agreement we're doing it we're
actually winning on that we're actually
reducing our carbon emissions in
accordance with it and the people who
did sign on are not doing that we ran
all of that we know all of the facts but
she believes that that slapping a higher
gas tax on middle-class Americans that
is tantamount to ending slavery that is
the kind of moral idiocy that happens
when we don't take real problems
seriously problems in the air and now
political problems temporal problems and
eternal problems a good note to leave on
at the beginning of Advent that is our
show tune into daily wire backstage we
have so much more coming up in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Noel's show I'll see you later
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018